conforme hacemos el análisis de
corriente alterna y hacemos operaciones
en el dominio de la frecuencia
necesitamos usar las leyes de kirkuk
para poder comprender los circuitos por
lo que en este vídeo veremos que la ley
de voltajes de kickoff funciona en el
dominio de la frecuencia aquí tenemos un
circuito con cierta fuente de voltaje de
corriente alterna que tiene tres
impedancia conectadas en serie adentro
de estas cajas podemos tener una r o una
l o una c pero no nos interesa cuáles
sean en este momento ya que las
trabajaremos como impedancia en el
análisis de sea los voltajes siempre son
ondas coseno por lo que es igual a
cierta amplitud de voltaje de cero por
el coseno de omega t más fisher o un
desplazamiento inicial de fase esta es
nuestra señal de entrada ahora vamos a
etiquetar los voltajes y todo lo demás
este es b1 y lo etiquetamos así este es
de dos que ponemos al revés y aquí está
b 3 - más de 3 y ya que aquí tenemos b 1
vamos a cambiar esto
de cero para que la i y el 1 no se nos
confundan el voltaje de entrada es de 0
y así está el voltaje cuando aplicamos
la ley de voltajes de kickoff nos dice
que elegimos un lugar en el circuito
para comenzar por ejemplo aquí y vamos a
alrededor del circuito y la suma debe
ser igual a 0 volts esto es el beca para
circuitos normales de sd y ahora veremos
cómo se aplica para circuitos o sea en
el dominio del tiempo decimos que de 0 +
b1 b2 b3 es igual a 0 que es lo que
sabemos sabemos que de 0 es una onda
coseno con cierto ángulo de fase que
sabemos sobre los demás voltajes en un
análisis sea lo que hacemos es buscar la
respuesta forzada por lo que dejamos que
la respuesta natural se desvanezca aquí
no tenemos un interruptor y suponemos
que este circuito ha estado así por
siempre por lo que la respuesta natural
ha desaparecido se desvanece sabemos que
tenemos tres voltajes y sabemos que
estos voltajes se parecieran al voltaje
de entrada por
todos serán senoidal es todos los
voltajes aquí serán senoidal es de
corriente alterna porque la función
forzada es una senoidal otra cosa que
sabemos es que todos tendrán la misma o
mega la frecuencia de todos estos
voltajes es la misma aquí ponemos signos
de admiración porque es muy importante
en un circuito desea cuando lo
alimentamos con cierta frecuencia
todas las demás frecuencias en este
circuito serán las mismas este es un
sistema lineal con componentes lineales
todo el análisis que hemos hecho nos
indica qué componentes lineales no crean
nuevas frecuencias así que todos tienen
la misma omega otra cosa que sabemos es
que tendremos desplazamiento de fase
recuerden que cuando vimos la impedancia
multiplicamos por jota y rotamos todos
90 grados por lo que tendremos fis
diferentes para cada uno
otra cosa que sabemos es que las
amplitudes de nuestras entidades serán
diferentes de n diferentes la amplitud
de b1 puede ser diferente de la amplitud
de b2
sin luz y dar una solución de sea veamos
que además encontramos lo que voy a
hacer es tomar este voltaje de entrada
más estas cosas que ya conocemos y
veremos cómo funciona la ley de voltajes
de kirk off en el dominio de la
frecuencia y trabajaremos con estas
impedancia vamos a hacerlo
trabajemos un poco en el dominio del
tiempo y vamos a escribir de nuevo
nuestra ecuación lv-ca de cero coseno de
omega t más fichero más de uno la
amplitud de nuestro voltaje 1 gusano de
omega tema si uno es un ángulo de fase
diferente que aún no conocemos más de
dos la amplitud de b2 coseno de omega
temas y dos más de tres la amplitud de
b3 coseno de omega t más fi 3
todo esto igual a 0 y todas estas omega
son iguales la misma frecuencia en
radiales todas las fish son diferentes y
las amplitudes de los voltajes también
son diferentes ahora pasemos a la
anotación de exponenciales complejas
vamos a cambiar la anotación podemos
en este número como la parte real de de
a la jota omega t más ficheros esto es
exactamente lo mismo que esto el coche
no representa la parte real de una
exponencial compleja con esta frecuencia
y puedo escribir lo demás así la parte
real de b1 por el ala j omega t más fino
más la parte real de dedos por el ala j
omega temas fi dos más la parte real de
v 3 por el ala j
omega temas filtres todo esto igual a 0
lo siguiente que vamos a hacer es
actualizar cosas vamos a descomponer
esto yo sé que si tengo esta expresión
en general
a la jota o mega temas film con las
propiedades de los exponenciales esto es
igual a e a la j
por e a la j omega te vamos a hacer esta
transformación para todos estos términos
de aquí la parte real de de 0 por e
la j 0 por el ala j o me gasté más la
parte real de 1 por el ala j 1 por e a
la jota omega t más la parte real d b2
por el ala jotas y 2 por el ala j omega
t más la parte real debe 3 porque a la j
filtres por el ala j omega t todo esto
igual a cero aquí tenemos una bonita
simplificación en donde factor izamos
este término en común de toda la
ecuación y nos queda que la parte real
de pc ero por a la jota fisher o más de
1 por a la jota y uno bien el patrón más
de dos porque a la jota y dos más de
tres porque a la jota filtres todo esto
porque a la jota omega t
todo esto es igual a 0 ya nos estamos
acercando cómo hacemos que esta ecuación
sea 0 alguna vez a la j omega tc vuelve
0 este término es un vector rotacional
por lo que nunca se vuelve 0 por lo que
será este término el que tiene que ser
cero como vamos a hacer esto vamos a
hacer un cambio de notación más este
número de aquí se conoce como factor es
una amplitud por él con un complejo y un
ángulo aquí arriba no tenemos tiempo el
tiempo sólo se encuentra por aquí este
es el único término en la ecuación en
donde tenemos el tiempo y omega estos
son solamente ángulos de fase por lo que
mi y notación para un factor será de 0
con una línea encima para indicar que es
un vector complejo y eso es igual a cero
porque al aj fichero así que si ven el
símbolo del vector
así que ponemos el índice del vector y
el subíndice aquí
finalmente podemos escribir la parte
real de de 0 más de 1 factor más de dos
pasos más b 3 factor igual a cero así
que esto es el bbk en el dominio de la
frecuencia
afortunadamente luce como la bbk que
recordamos del análisis se de la suma de
los voltajes alrededor de un circuito o
lazo es igual a cero en este caso es la
suma de los factores alrededor de un
lazo es igual a cero